يعتبر اختبار المريض إيجابيًا
لوقت الفيروس التاجي أمرًا بالغ الأهمية لتتبع مكان تواجده ومن
شاهده.تقول كوريا الجنوبية إنه يمكنها الوصول إلى هذه
المعلومات في أقل من 10 دقائق
إذا تم تأكيد إصابتي بفيروس كورونا ، فماذا
ستفعل بعد ذلك  رقم الهاتف المحمول ،
حدد رقم بطاقة الائتمان
الفترة الزمنية وتظهر جميع المعلومات
التي نحتاجها في نظامنا ،
موقعك من يومين على الأقل قبل
أن تلاحظ أنك تعاني من الأعراض ، المدة
التي قضيتها في كل مكان ، مدى
الانشغال بالمنطقة
يتم بعد ذلك إرسال تنبيهات الطوارئ للجمهور في
بعض الأحيان ستة أو سبعة أيام لإخبارك
عن الحالات في منطقتك ، لم يكن الأمر
بهذه السرعة دائمًا
، وتقول المراكز الكورية لمكافحة الأمراض والوقاية منها (KCDC) إن الأمر استغرق ما يصل إلى 48 ساعة
للحصول على نفس المعلومات قبل خمس سنوات
أثناء تفشي متلازمة الشرق الأوسط التنفسية  أدى انتقاد
الاستجابة البطيئة في ذلك الوقت إلى
تغيير القانون بحيث يمكن للمسؤولين الآن استخدام
كشوفات المرضى سجلات الهاتف المحمول
معاملات بطاقات الائتمان لقطات CCTV
لتتبع دقيق للإرسال  في أحد
الأمثلة الحديثة في الحي الذي أعيش فيه ،
يُظهر مقدار التفاصيل التي تتم مشاركتها
مع الجمهور من قبل كل من الحكومة
والشركات المحلية ، على سبيل المثال ، أعرف
المواقع الدقيقة التي ذهب إليها هذا الشخص
وأعرف الباب الذي
استخدموه للدخول إلى بلدي المحلي.  سوبر ماركت
حتى أنني أعلم أنهم اشتروا الفلفل الحار المجفف
عند الدفع الذاتي ، لذا فهل
يمكن استخدام هذا النموذج في مكان آخر ، فهذه ليست
تقنية متقدمة ، والفرق هو أنه في
حين أن البلدان الأخرى لديها قوانين تسمح
لهم باستخدام هذه المعلومات الشخصية ،
فهناك الكثير من تطبيقات الفيروسات التاجية
هنا.  خريطة توضح كل حالة في
منطقتك وفي جميع أنحاء البلاد
بدأها الطلاب الذين اعتمدتهم
الحكومة وتطبيق يوضح
الصيدليات التي تحتوي حاليًا على أقنعة في المخازن
لكن الحكومة تقول إن هذا
النظام يستخدم البيانات الضخمة لتتبع المواطنين
الذين ثبتت إصابتهم بالفيروس.
الخطوة الأولى الرئيسية في سياستهم الخاصة
باختبار التتبع تعامل بولا هانكوكس سي إن إن سيئول